this is the welcome back to the D show
special guest Sheikh Mustafa Salaam
alaikum peace be with you however till
I'm excellent how are you now you are
good humble ah you weren't always in a
position where you're at you're actually
educating people teaching people the
purpose of life inviting people to have
a relationship with the one who created
creation but you are actually fighting
against it as an atheist but you are
Muslim first so you are Muslim carrying
Behati the books of ahadees on your back
and then you took a philosophy class and
when my faith story takes off from there
let's go back it up now let's let's talk
from the beginning a little bit give us
some highlights how it all started yes I
mean I grew up in a Muslim family you
can say not very practicing a little bit
more cultural than Muslim we kind of
went for you know Friday prayers
sometimes we fasted Ramadan but that's
pretty much it so didn't really have
that many Islamic teachings went to
Sunday school didn't pay attention
didn't really understand what was going
on there no one was really interested in
that so I kind of grew up that way
Islam was just something like it's part
of a culture we didn't understand what
was going on and then in my junior year
of high school we took a trip to Mecca
and we went for the Umrah the the minor
pilgrimage and that was just seeing a
different world for me that just changed
things completely so there I go into a
bookstore and I'm seeing the Kaaba I'm
seeing you know muck the people there
hearing the athan the call to prayer on
a regular basis motions there's a lot of
emotions there it's like just a
different society never seen anything
like this in my life you know and I've
traveled a lot and walk into a bookstore
and they got actually like you know I
see Islamic books for the first time in
my life I see translations of hadith the
statements of the Prophet peace be upon
him
I see translations of the Quran and I
was like you know what I can investigate
this I can you know learn more about
this so I buy a translation of the Quran
I buy a Suhail body you know a
collection of sayings of the Prophet
peace be upon him nine volumes carry it
back with me on the airplane I say you
know I'm going to try to learn about
this religion of mine I'm going to going
to find out if it's the truth or not so
I come back I
reading and I start you know
appreciating Islam so you know I'm going
to find this out find out on my own
what is Islam what is this thing that I
was raised on supposedly what is this
all supposed to mean
and I started becoming more interested
in I say this seems like it's the truth
I started comparing what I know about
Hinduism I said you know I can't worship
a statue you know something like that
I heard thing about Christianity I can't
believe that you know like a man is
going to be God
Judaism that's I don't have the right
blood in me you know so these things
don't work for me I see Islam is the
thing that kind of makes sense you know
if we're going to believe in God that's
like the the religion which I can
consider so I start getting more and
more you know learning about Islam on my
own reading the Quran reading these
books of hadith and I start to have like
a appreciation for Islam did you have a
teacher did you have someone giving you
some direction so that was the issue so
I did not have a teacher and one of the
reasons why I didn't have a teacher is
you know everyone I had met they seem to
be very more cultural than Islamic or
Muslim so I don't know who to go to for
for knowledge I go to the mosque I hear
the sermon it seems like very emotional
person has a very thick accent I'm
really not interested in this I'm gonna
figure this all out all on my own
no direction no direction I'm gonna read
the text whatever I think the text means
doesn't matter what they're saying in
the book that's what the way I'm gonna
take about from family or how much
directions you get from Papa mama see
the thing is you know they may say a few
things here and there but it's all mixed
with Islam and culture mixed not a
culture a lot of culture and I'm very
I'm not into culture because for me it's
like you know I if I don't understand
why this is happening I don't want to
follow something blindly how was your
basic understanding of let's say the the
pure monotheism some toe to toe heed the
fundamental belief system how was that
you know I I probably understood that
there's one God that that was pretty
clear but anything beyond that adds
attributes and you know even though even
the idea of you know belief in angels
and things which are unseen so the
fundamental the core was not there not
really there so I'm reading these books
and I'm getting interested I'm learning
more I'm thinking hey this is uh it
seems to make sense I start you know I
start questioning a lot of things
all I said you know let me start praying
okay I think we know I know we should
pray but it doesn't make sense to pray
in Arabic I don't even know what I'm
saying you know and even if I read what
I'm saying the translation I tried doing
Arabic and then translating in English
I'm like this is distracting me let me
just start praying in English so I just
started praying in English seems like
it's not a bad idea seems like a good
idea what is your logic yeah I say at
least at least you know for me maybe it
was a little bit arrogant at the time
but at least I understand what I'm
saying and all the people around me made
my parents my friends family they're
saying all these formulas but they don't
even know what they're saying right many
of them don't even bother to read the
translation so I feel like hey at least
I'm connecting with God on a deeper
level cuz I know what I'm saying so I'm
doing this I'm praying in English I'm
kind of praying while I'm driving if I'm
getting late somewhere it's better than
you know God should except for me at
least I'm doing better than what I was
doing before so I'm kind of you know
feeling good about this kind of having
some you know positive healthy pride in
Islam start discussing debating with my
friends come on you guys got to believe
in God look at the Quran this is you
know this is a miracle chart chart
getting very very happy about you know
being a Muslim and that's when you know
I started you know almost got to a point
where I saw some things within hadith
that I was reading and I got and I said
you know what some of these hadees seem
just very strange they don't seem to
make sense to me they don't they don't
seem to be as like rational as i was
seeing in the quran so i got to a point
where i came across a website called
like the submitters or something like
that they basically said we don't need
to accept these hadees hadees has all
this weird stuff going on just remove
this hadith just go with the Quran only
so I basically got into that movement or
that group
intellectually on online and I just said
you know let's just focus on the Quran
some hadith are nice but some are weird
so I don't understand them really it's
going to stick to the Quran what
happened was I go to college get
accepted to UC Irvine decide to take a
class on philosophy walk into that class
on philosophy and the professor starts
talking about you know how people
believe in so many strange things today
you know you guys grew up believing in
the tooth fairy
you grew up believing in Santa Claus
your parents had tricked you about these
things and I'm like yeah that's true man
my parents you know I remember the tooth
fairy I was pretty a tricked into
believing in the Santa Claus for a while
Halloween all that stuff and then he
said how many you still believe in that
ones like come on we don't believe in
that and then he threw the bomb and he
goes how many of you still believe in
God and that's where I was just like you
know do I raise my hand why not raise my
so is anybody raising their hand at this
moment nobody raises their hand except
one guy who was the weird Christian
missionary guy who like everyone hated
he's just like he seems like mentally
deficient or something like that you
know so something's wrong with this guy
so I raise my hand I'm like look I
believe in God and just me and him and
no one else in the class and I just that
was just like a moment for me I'm like
am I like this guy is it might be only
one like what's the pressures on really
the pressure is sweating really I'm
thinking what what have I been raised on
you know I thought that everyone
believes in God I grew up believing like
this and that just questioned my faith
and it just it just it just changed my
entire perception and everything this
went downhill from there I became super
skeptical and I got to a point from
agnosticism not knowing if there's God
to basically sliding down into atheism
and saying you know what God doesn't
exist all this religion is man-made it's
all you know it's all just hodgepodge
it's something of the past we need to
get away from me we got a Muslim who
left Islam and this is a very sad
situation I'm sure many have been
affected by this you actually went
through it the story doesn't stop there
we got more when we come back don't go
anywhere
Salaam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind
subscribe right now and enjoy all of the
content that we're going to be putting
out for you thank you
peace be with you so I'm like back here
on the D show Muslim leaves Islam I
don't see your heads off yet yeah not a
body didn't come with a machete looking
for you no they did not okay because uh
now a lot of people they try to use this
now that okay you obviously how did your
family did they know now that you had
had turned away from you know I didn't
tell I didn't tell them openly but I
told them that you know what I'm not
interested in praying I'm not interested
in going to the mosque don't even ask me
to go on Friday anymore it's obviously
it's pretty obvious that this this guy
is far from the from the religion yeah
now what happens okay that's the moment
you go in when you're carrying Behati
you know the hadith on your back but I
asked you how was really your core
understanding was kind of very weak
tanned have a bright teacher you walk
into this philosophy class you come in
you know to a gunfight with you know a
pencil yeah and and what what after that
you left the class really just
disenfranchise your yeah I'm lost now
lost your faith is questioned and
everything is going out the window
yep and then I started you know then
that that's when I kind of you know got
into a group of friends where I probably
wouldn't have considered them when I was
Muslim so I started getting into this
group of friends that are telling me you
know go let's go to nightclubs let's go
to raves let's just party let's have fun
that seems fun huh it's it seems fun at
the time he opens up now that's it that
every now you know the the shackles are
coming off and you know when you're a
freshman in college it's like you just
dying to get out of you know the the
confines of your home your parents have
always been kind of holding you back
saying it's for your own good now now I
mean the dorms in college now I have you
know some level of freedom even though
my parents are trying to you know spy on
me from time to time is this guy you
know is he crazy is he doing drugs
what's going on so I start having fun
and I get I get or suppose it fun you
know and I get into the wrong group
start going to these clubs start going
to raves and kind of strange you know
like I'm not really believing but I have
like these I kind of sometimes I feel
like you know should I should I consider
praying should I not consider praying
there's still some doubts going on
there's there's there's doubts about not
being Muslim as well like the way that
there were doubts about being Muslim so
I'm kind of going in down this road and
I get into street racing with with the
cars basically so just a furious kind of
like fast and furious basically inspired
by all these movies inspired by what was
going around in my area so I get with
this group and we start street racing
and we just it's it's a very dangerous
thing I in retrospect I tell people you
don't realize what you're doing you know
one one mistake you know pedestrian
walking down the street you can just hit
someone kill someone and you don't even
feel it's like a video game almost in
front of you you know
so start street racing and that's going
on for a while and one day I just get
really upset with my parents I get upset
with just everything I'm upset with life
I'm upset with the world and I lost a
lot of money that my parents had given
me in the stock market that day it was a
Friday the stock market crashes I lose a
ton of money I'm stressed out I'm mad at
my parents I got my juicer you're kind
of a spoiled rich kid kind of a spoiled
rich kid that's just the reality you
know I'm driving a Lexus is 300 the same
month that it came out you know it was a
big deal when it came out so that's
pretty much what's happening so I'm
really upset and I decided I'm running
away from home I've had it now I need my
absolute freedom I don't even want to
come home on the weekends anymore I'm
out of here so I get my stuff I have
money in my bank account so my parents
had given me everything's ready ready to
go jump in the car run away from home
never coming back again on my way I'm
driving from Orange County down to San
Diego it's kind of a windy road
all of a sudden Nissan 300zx pulls up
twin turbo tries to race me and I'm in a
bad mood I'm really upset listening to
rock music just you know fueling more
anger and I decide you know what that's
it man I'm going to race this guy so we
race and we're going really really fast
and my car spins out of control
literally does a u-turn on the freeway
at a very very fast speed we'll just
leave it at that
and for car accident five car accident
something like that I don't get injured
the car is totaled I walk out perfectly
fine people start telling me that you
know what God saved you for a reason
like yeah God whatever you know so I
started thinking about it in the back of
my mind and then when the police came to
me and so you know what you going to
jail that's when I started just freaking
out all my pleasures are going to be
gone all my enjoyment all my fun it's
all going to be done what do I do
so I start thinking you know what maybe
it's time to make some change in my life
maybe I need to take life a little bit
more seriously
so my friends come back to me is like
come on let's go let's just go to the
raves man just come back don't worry
don't let one car accident you know get
you down we're gonna go back into the
same lifestyle that we can always count
on those uh good friends right exactly
exactly you know so there's that that
whispering coming you know they're
trying to come to my room and everything
and I just decide I don't want to see
you guys I just need to figure things
out for myself what's going on and
that's when I decided you know what
after a while of struggling I said you
know what there's no one else to turn to
so when you have no one else to turn to
and you don't even know what to do
that's when I started praying and I say
you know what god I don't know if you
exist I don't even know if I really
believe in you or not but if you exist
show me that you exist and show me show
me why I'm here if there's a purpose in
life
show me that purpose and before I had
asked that probably before but I never
put any effort into it
so this time what was different is
there's more sincerity because I'm
saying and I'm gonna put the effort in
to find you so I'm going to search I
don't know where to search I don't know
what to do but I'm going to put in my
effort you send me something use you
throw me a little something so I can you
know I can find you so that's when I
started saying you know I don't want to
do this
I'm not playing anymore I'm going to be
serious about life until I try to figure
this out I started going to the library
I start reading books on philosophy to
overcome some of the things that I learn
in philosophy class and reading books on
Islam reading books on Christianity I
started reading different religions
reading more in detail about Islam
reading about philosophy
and reading all that kind of you know
help me start to address some of the
questions I used to have but I never got
good answers but how is your heart at
this moment it's different than it was
before because you have a desire to want
to know yes instead of covering the
truth exactly you're open I'm open now
and and now I'm focusing because you
know it's not about the worldly
pleasures anymore now it's not about you
know I'm not going to sit there and say
I'll read one line off that doesn't make
sense I'm just gonna go go go to a rave
and just you know nothing just just just
get rid of it that's the difference you
know so now the difference is I'm not
gonna waste my time I'm gonna give as
much as I can in my life to focus on
what what needs to get done and you had
read some of the top atheist books yep I
know well where was your atheist now I
mean it was seemed like it was abandon
you was it yes I mean so what had
happened I bought a book about you know
critiques of God the strongest arguments
against God and long time ago I'd bought
it and I'm lucky I can re I can respond
to all this so I'm like okay let me go
when I was when I was still a Muslim I'm
like you know what I'm gonna show them
that all this is wrong and when I was
reading it oh man this sounds very
intellectual and very rational I go to
the mosque for Friday prayer the guy
seems very emotional he seems to be
getting upset
I said yeah this seems like I don't I
don't have any response to it right now
I still got that book on my shelf but
now I'm not just comparing these things
for 10 minutes and then going and having
fun now I'm going to sit all day with
this book and I'm going to go all day
and I'm a look at what Islam says if
there's any answers about it I'm really
gonna sit there and reflect I'm gonna
you know keep on asking God for guidance
and that makes a world of difference
when you put some real effort into it
and you have real like sincerity and
desire to actually invest time and
effort into it that's I think what
really really you know helped me that's
how that's how God helped me was that
the innate nature you know about that
Oxford study with the 52 plus the
anthropology department in Oxford I did
a study saying that innate that belief
is innate innate within people yet yet
was so was it coming out now with the
God hot spot in your brain was that now
coming out and yet from your heart from
your consciousness exactly what happens
it was covered up and it gets covered up
by our desires by our pleasures and just
running after these
things now that I'm like you know what
this is not my number one priority in
life I'm not going to run after you just
go and eating in fancy restaurants and
just going to go do and have fun and all
that now some of these later start
coming obviously I'm willing to be open
now now I'm really going to go and
analyze and that that natural
disposition starts coming back this is a
really really interesting they've
actually done documentaries of Muslims
suppose the Muslims who leaving Islam
and they're kind of insane struggles so
I'm sure you know those who are sincere
they also can truly benefit because you
were there and now the story is not over
we got more to share Andy show don't go
anywhere
salam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind subscribe right now
and enjoy all of the content that we're
going to be putting out for you thank
you peace be with you so I'm like back
here on the D show with Mustafa Sheikh
Mustafa now do we see this happening
more and more that because you're born
in a family you don't have that proper
direction good examples for let's say
from your family teaching you properly
and you don't have that guidance from a
young age and now you end up kind of
drifting off the whole world opens up
you can start going to the raves to the
nightclubs culture a lot of culture
strange things associated with Salaam
they have nothing to do with Islam and
now you have people leaving all right
it's very common it's very very common
and I encounter it on a regular basis on
a regular basis so like you know it's
not that I'm alone almost everywhere I
go I see people who literally that's
exactly how I was and I see them asking
the same kind of questions and some of
them are interested in having a further
discussion and others they just they
just go away from it so you know I can
see them going down the same path and I
don't know if someone had asked me back
in the day that you know what hey why
don't you have a conversation or some of
that I might have ran away as well I
don't know what would happen to me so I
I can relate I can relate to people and
I can almost see exactly what they're
going through I'm not the only one who
went through this but now you came back
not just an average Muslim I mean you
went you the yearning actually an imam
at a mosque in yes spiritual leader you
you run the College of Islamic studies I
mean how can someone before they get in
a train wreck car wreck
maybe diet and after-party yeah who
knows because death is a reality and
come at any time before they go through
all this drama now maybe end up no no
where you actually you ended up
somewhere you know figuring out the
purpose of life why you've been created
you know on a path of goodness how can
summer what let's derive some good from
this story again people don't make the
same mistake yeah they can avoid all
those uh you know pitfalls yeah I mean I
I tell people you know when I tell them
my story you know I don't share that
often but when I tell them my story they
almost some people come up to me and
they say you know I wish I had a similar
story so that I could change I said no
this you don't want this story you don't
want a near-death experience you know
because you might actually die before
you change and you don't need to have an
experience like this you don't need to
get into a car accident to change this
is a way you know some people they have
this and they don't change many people
go through something similar and they
just go right back into the same life
that they went into so there's no
guarantee and you don't need this type
of experience a change if you have a
willingness you have a sincerity you
have a desire that you know what you you
want it you want to look into this more
seriously you realize that you know what
it's worth just investigating and
finding out you know what the truth is
why we've been created in the first
place so that you can figure out that
you know what if there's an afterlife if
God is going to hold us accountable if
this is really a test what can I do to
prepare for that test to make sure that
I pass it you know so people can wake up
without these experiences and what my
advice to them would basically be is
take life a little bit more seriously
you know there's a lot of distractions
there's a lot of fun and games there's
going to be those friends who come they
try to grab you and say come on let's
just go have fun you know you start you
attend the class you maybe you would you
you benefit from a Friday sermon you
watch a youtube video and you're kind of
like yeah you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
focus on this I'm going to be interested
in this and then all of a sudden some of
us forget all that let's just go watch a
movie and you just forget all of it
this is this
something that we should be careful
about we really really need to reflect
upon yet what can we do how can we
change ourselves and the first step in
changing yourself is with knowledge
actually learning properly or what is
the religion of Islam what is the
ultimate meaning behind these things
what is the meaning behind these rituals
why are we doing these things and go
beyond all that and not get caught up
into all these small things over here
what if someone says look you had the
knowledge you had Mahadi books on your
back and you still left what do you say
the thing is there was no foundation and
the key is to have a good Islamic
foundation because what a foundation
does it basically it contextualizes
everything I got body books in front of
me but I don't know how to interpret
these statements that are in there I
don't even know exactly who bahati is I
don't know when he wrote this book I
don't know how we know that the Prophet
peace be upon him actually said these
things so I just heard this is authentic
but I don't have a deep foundation I
don't know how to interpret the Quran if
I read it I don't understand you know
what does this pronoun refer to us it
doesn't refer to something else who's
this talking about I it talks about you
know the battle of badr it says when the
incident happened at butter what is
mother buttered if you don't have a
context you don't know any of these
things right so it's very important to
have a context and to have a very wide
understanding like an overview of what
Islam is so you everything you read it
kind of fits into like a puzzle and you
see the entire thing in front of you
with that context you understand it's
not properly what if someone says we
have a theist same situation maybe his
friend got him to watch and he says come
on all you religious people I got my
Christian friend he said you know he's
to drink do drugs raid party same thing
but he saw Jesus in a dream now all
right and he's a born-again what's the
difference like the difference is that
you need you know people say well I had
some personal experience or something
that that could be a true experience it
can be a false experience but there's
got to be a way if there is a God and if
you know if there's a real purpose in
life there's got to be an objective way
of us being able to figure out what the
truth is and my response name would be
you look around the world you look at
your own body you look at everything out
there and you say you know what who
created all these things you start from
the idea that there's a creator you
start from the idea that all of this
didn't happen by random
it's the probability of it coming
together and it happening is not very is
not very strong at all it is you really
got to have a leap of faith to believe
in something like that that all of this
is just a product of chance once you
establish belief in the creator and that
there is a God now you need to learn
about that God learn something about him
and that's when you go and you look at
the different scriptures look at the
different religions and look at the core
of what are these religions actually
teaching and when you come to Islam
you're going to find that it has that
pristine message it has that message
which basically says that there's only
one God you should worship that one God
and that God when he created people he
didn't just leave them in darkness to
just kind of figure out things on their
own have fun maybe some of them will
take it seriously and he didn't leave it
up to people to kind of wait to have
some kind of spiritual experience where
they're gonna you know figure out on
their own okay this is what God wants me
to do or he's communicating directly he
sent us guidance and the guidance is in
people who received revelation we can
objectively evaluate that revelation
read the Quran see if this makes sense
do the teachings make sense we can read
the life of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him we can see if he did he have
an ulterior motive could he have been a
liar
does he look like someone who would have
made up something like this and undergo
all the difficulties that he's coming
with so when we use our minds we use our
intellects and our hearts are also you
know open to this we will arrive at the
reality in the conclusion that you know
what this is something that makes sense
and that's really what a lot of people
say when they when they when they look
at Islam they come from other religions
other backgrounds and they're like none
of this really made sense when you study
Islam in a proper way
within this proper context the thing
that people always say it just makes
sense it just makes sense makes it just
makes sense and tell us we're out of
time and short I've really benefited
from the college of Islamic Studies tell
us a little bit short about this and how
people can go ahead this is a great
place to start also now yes so at the
college of Islamic Studies is really
it's a program where people can attend
live or they can actually take classes
online and this is designed we have 18
or 19 different classes it's designed to
give you that foundation in Islam so
that you don't get lost like I did
so that you understand what the context
is and it prioritizes what Islamic
studies are many people they just pick
up the Quran start reading or they pick
up a hadith book start reading but they
don't have any context behind that and
it's very important to have a context
you know beyond all that so I would
recommend everyone check out our website
which is College Islam calm you can
enroll in classes you can enroll online
anywhere you are any any place around
the world we have students in different
countries around the world I recommend
that people at least try a class and I
guarantee that you're going to benefit
and you're going to see Islam in a
different light beautiful thank you so
much thank you very much I don't like
home just Oklahoma sit up please be with
love peace be with you as well Salam
says love all mankind that's why we're
sharing this message because we want the
best for you and we want the best for
all mankind
we'll see you next time God willing on
the Deen show continue to tune in peace
be on to you please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below